um you know for all you know i could
have been lying man i mean you know it
was a nice flex how'd you make you know
uh less than seven million i mean how
did you get into lessons without putting
out music during a pandemic um
man just being more on honestly being
more mindful of my business more mindful
everything i do is a business expense
you know it's a write-off
um investing in the real estate stocks
and bond this is just how you attain
wealth in general just in general more
so generalizing my turn not saying how i
made more or less right right right
yeah but like you're actually putting
money into yeah yeah and stocks bonds
real estate
um
i'm not too big on a crypto wave because
um
i would have to do a lot more research
on that but i i'm super like old school
more so with my safe stocks i found a
couple of gold mines like neo nio which
is like the chinese tesla
um
and i got into the stock market at a
great time this is when covey first
happened with it when it first happened
everything was it's super low no no the
dow jones was on the 19 000 right now
it's at like 37 or something like that
so i dumped into it i was just like i
have i'm in this blessed position to
have access to all this extra capital so
i just dumped in it you know doing
certain brand endorsement deals things
of that nature like what is their
biggest non-rap check been so far don't
tell us don't tell us how much just yeah
where was it from
puma puma all day
[ __ ] poo man they man i had to
downgrade my lifestyle when the pandemic
have i'm like [ __ ] nick we might have to
start [ __ ] doing uh swipe ups
on the stories and promos and [ __ ] for
this is like i'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] how are
we gonna do this we doing shows like
[ __ ] now but you know i didn't have to
downgrade my lifestyle at all that's
dope god is good are they gonna give you
your own sneaker soon yes on the works
right now yeah cause cold sneakers fire
yeah i feel like you're you gotta get
your sneaker man yeah nice and it's
already in the works it's gonna be high
level are you whatever you're gonna be
involved in the silhouette and the
designs yeah yeah my boy uh ian rutledge
my boy ian michael excuse me uh shout
out to him has been helping on a design
as well so uh it's gonna be i don't know
mellow's a puma guy yeah yeah now puma
and i've been with puma like er they've
been rocking with me earlier like i
remember mellow before a bunch and not
saying you know whatever but i remember
a lot of these cats they've been rocking
with me
early early you know it was in the
location my locations video location
ships video was paid for by puma you
know so that i called them like my fairy
godmother man like because
they they just they treat me well over
there like no even like for my uh the
arm release they sent me like [ __ ]
ace of spades bottle and like man they
like they treat me really well like when
i'm doing things in conjunction with
puma they'll like fly me on like the
puma jet like i really [ __ ] with that
company man and even more than that
they're like very and i'm not just
saying this because i'm getting a check
for sure this and that because with as
an artist it's a fine line you can't
become like too brand heavy because you
lose like you're you'll just look like
you'll do whatever for a dollar you know
so i try to remain like very reclusive
when it comes to brand alignment with
anything anybody
and i think the less brand deals you
have is more cool because i could just
because of like who i am and the type of
the lane i'm in i could [ __ ] be
cashing out you'll be on brands all the
days
but i yeah but i'll be slutting myself
out and in the long term if i'm just
taking every single brand deal every
year for sure and so i say that to say
that puma's been in alignment with what
i have for my vision and they're always
like helping with community projects
things that i'll never like have on
camera these are things that's just for
for my good karma and for to actually
help people they really like
into the community and things of that
nature so they got to do a puma
commercial with you lamello
and the best puma athlete the starting
center for the best team in the nba
deandre ayton yeah shout out to the
facebook oh you are shout out cp3 that's
my boy
yeah that's my dog